il est remonté sur le cheval de la
politique active jean charest candidat à
la direction du parti conservateur du
canada est avec nous ce char et bonsoir
le rodéo de la politique active oui puis
odeillo via des bols d'abord vous
regrettez pas monsieur chars et c est
tout ah non non non pas du tout
c'est une course où on voit votre
adversaire c'est un combat âpre et
skadden monsieur poilievre d'un côté
vous de l'eau et quand on lit les
journaux l'impression qu'ils qui semble
rallier plus de mandat les assemblées de
face que ça j'ai dans une période où
j'étais inquiet ou qu on continue le
combat j'étais en train de vous dire que
je pense c'est difficile pour le public
et les médias d'avoir une lisibilité sur
la campagne vous étiez deux adversaires
principaux sauf que c'est un vote
préférentiel en c'est un bulletin de
vote vous choisissez votre premier choix
2 3 4 et là il ya une élimination
naturelle qui se fait lors des deux
dernières courses le meneur a perdu
parce qu'ils plafonnent dès le premier
tour et là bas les votes vont vers celui
qu'il pût faire
éventuellement alors c'est ce qui est
arrivé est dans la course actuelle tout
dépend des membres il ya des membres
nous nous avons jusqu'au 3 juin prochain
pour recruter des nouveaux membres qui
voteront pendant l'été sur un bulletin
qui arrivera par la poste alors à tous
ceux qui veulent me soutenir on leur dit
allez à jean charest point ca prenez
votre carte de membre vous je pense j'ai
vu mon nom sur la liste non monsieur
charest le 3 juin si vous n'êtes pas
arriver à vendre plus de cartes lui
est-ce que c'est fini il ya moi j'ai
encore dans la dernière course monsieur
mais qui est vendue 30 mai le kart
o'toole 20000 leslie lwin d'e-mails
elodie mal à l'accepter vous savez tout
le jeu se fera dans cette mécanique
cette logique d'un bulletin
préférentiels mais un premier deuxième
troisième choix alors il faut recruter
des nouveaux membres tout se joue
monsieur roy ce niveau là tout est dans
les grandes campagnes qui se font paul y
ait fait des rassemblements les laines
luis fait des églises patrick brown lui
fait des communautés culturelles et le
fait privé miles n'y a pas de campagne
publique moi je fais du terrain et je
fais du contenu ok par l'inconnu pour
avoir bien d'entrée pour être accepté
par les membres de ce nouveau parti
conservateur coin différent de celui que
vous aviez connu il ya des choses et des
mots-clés là qu'il faut que vous disiez
par exemple vous êtes maintenant contre
la taxe carbone bah vous êtes résolument
pour des pipelines et l'exportation de
pétrole et de gaz qui est j'ai toujours
été mais la taxe carbone ne voulait pas
toujours non non non non attention
lorsque j'ai d'ailleurs je suis le seul
à avoir annoncé une politique sur le
climat est le seul à avoir annoncé une
politique sur l'énergie la est ce que je
dis c'est qu'il y aurait une
tarification carbone y aura un prix sur
le carbone mais sur les grands émetteurs
et bien sûr oui c'est exactement ce que
nous avons et ce que j'ai fait au québec
avec le système que nous avons mis en
place maintenant en californie la bourse
du carbone c'est exactement ça il n'y a
pas de taxe aux consommateurs ou au
québec c'est une taxe sur les grands
émetteurs sous les tarifs sur les grands
émetteurs avec une bourse de carbone
avec la californie alors moi ce que je
propose c'est d'avoir une approche
similaire au niveau canadien et en
passant le commissaire à l'environnement
le lendemain mon annonce publié un
rapport où il collabore qu' il faut
faire davantage sur les grands émetteurs
mais dont je suis membre
calgary puis je vous demande là je
rencontre le candidat je me suis charest
est ce que vous êtes pour ou contre une
taxe carbone caisse bercy je suis
favorable à un prix sur le carbone et
c'est ce que j'ai dit car la détaxe bas
prix taxes celles un prix sur le carbone
ça revient un prix qui sera payé pour
chaque tonne de carbone qui sera émis
alors c'est pas la même chose que la
taxe de monsieur trudeau c'est pour ça
que les mous les gens jouent sur les
mots les gens veulent pas de la taxe
dans la formule qu'a proposé monsieur
trudeau ma passe en passant le suroît ce
que je dis à calgary c'est ce que je dis
au québec c'est ce que je dis à moncton
je tiens le même discours partout de la
même façon sur tous les sujets c'est
très populaire en effet que de promettre
d'autres puis plein dans l'ouest seul et
moins au québec c'est évident si vous
voulez faire renaître des projets comme
l'énergie est par exemple pour que le
pétrole de l'ouest peut savoir des
débouchés commerciaux
si le gouvernement du québec vous dis
non vous faites quoi on respecte les
compétences du gouvernement du québec
c'est fini et c'est ce que j'ai dit
l'ami communication au passage qu'on
respecte les compétences du gouvernement
du québec mais attention prenons un
projet comme gnl québec dans le saguenay
pour le gaz grt-gaz bon aloi yens guerre
actuellement en europe et depuis
quelques jours la russie vient de couper
l'alimentation au gaz la pologne est à
la mode d'avis et un contexte que quand
même changé qui différent de celui que
nous avions au moment où les discussions
ont été prises et c'est quand même cruel
avoir monsieur ahoua d écouter les
bulletins duels tous les soirs radio
canada c'est le brise le coeur de voir
les européens financer indirectement que
les russes pour envahir l'ukraine en
achetant leur gaz et pétrole alors que
nous nous on pourrait être un
fournisseur éthiques un fournisseur à ce
marché prenons gnl québec là encore le
gouvernement du québec étaient arrivés à
la conclusion qu'ils avaient pas
d'acceptabilité sociale
ça marche pas c'est fini bâton vous vous
avez un sport de faire renaître ça et
d'avoir l'accord du québec en plus les
circonstances ont évolué beaucoup depuis
que cette décision était rendue la
guerre en ukraine amiens en relief des
éléments très importants d'abord le fait
qu' il ya un enjeu de sécurité
d'approvisionnement qui se pose
maintenant au canada au québec comme
ailleurs dans le monde c'est à dire la
capacité que nous avons
d'alimenter de s'alimenter en énergie
deuxième enjeu celui d'alimenter
l'europe en énergie et de d'éviter
qu'ils soient à la merci d'un dictateur
puis le troisième c'est celui de poutine
qui coupent l'alimentation à des pays là
c'est pas ça passerait pas de la fiction
et tout ça arrive après la décision mais
dans aucun cas de figure vous imposerez
un pays plein ou un truc pour le gaz il
faut que l'accord des provinces parce
que j'ai été j'ai été premier ministre
du québec je respecte les compétences
des provinces et du québec il faut
respecter les compétences on passera pas
à côté alors mais ça veut pas dire qu'on
peut pas travailler ensemble mais et
réaliser des roger est d'ailleurs le
dernier projet de pipeline que ces faits
au québec ça a été fait sous mon
gouvernement sait le pipeline qui passe
oui
ça prouve monsieur roy qu'on est capable
de vote plein éliminé l'ingérence
politique dans les projets pétroliers
ça veut dire quoi ça moins d'état moins
de contrôle - d'environnement ça veut
dire que le processus d'évaluation
environnementale doit être fait dans des
délais qui sont prévisibles à des
conditions où on entend les témoins qui
sont directement concernés par les
projets et puis on évite de partir dans
toutes sortes de directions moi j'ai vu
des processus d'évaluation
environnementale où on permet à peu près
n'importe quoi ce que nous voulons c'est
un vrai processus rigoureux où on entend
la preuve on entend les faits on entend
les gens parler de l'acceptabilité
sociale mais au lieu de partir dans
toutes les directions sa vie et les
processus déjà
on veut que ce soit ligue ou re ont vu
que ce soit bien fait on veut pas que
celui né l'ingérence politique ça veut
dire qu'il ya des gens qui en font une
bataille idéologique ou purement
idéologique et qui par toutes sortes de
procédures réussissent à retarder les
processus d'évaluation environnementale
suroît alors que l'objectif c'est pas de
simplement étirer le processus pour
l'heure l'intéressé alors que les gens
investissent des milliards de dollars en
mai l'impression que ça donne c'est que
vous les débrider un peu tout seul à
dire allez-y relais j'ai fait est que
les faits monsieur moi je ne fais de rod
sur ces enjeux là je peux je parle j'ai
pas peur de le dire j'ai quand même
suivi au cours de toute ma carrière
politique un certain nombre de règles
sur les processus environnementale et
c'est une chose qui est fondamental
c'est d'avoir des processus qui sont
prévisibles des règles sont transparents
ils sont faits dans un délai raisonnable
si vous le faites pas vous allez
handicapés tout le processus parce que
la question fondamentale d'enfants que
je vous pose depuis début c est ce que
pour séduire les militants de ce parti
qui a changé encore une fois il faut pas
que vous vous dédié vous renier en
passant par rapport aux objectifs de
théâtre fait deux fois que vous dites
c'est que le parti charge vous même vous
l'aviez dit oui mais je vous faire un
commentaire des partis politiques c'est
des institutions vivantes elles sont
fondées sur des valeurs et les
conservateurs et des valeurs qui sont
conservatrices auxquelles je crois mais
les partis politiques comme institution
vivante évolué avec le temps à chaque
chef marc le parti et le parti a
continué à évoluer je le prendrais dans
l'état où il est lorsque je deviendrai
chef est ce que je propose monsieur roy
après tout ce que j'ai vécu en politique
c'est des choses auxquelles je crois
profondément
alors c'est pas vrai que j allais dire
des choses vous faire des choses pour
essayer simplement de plaire et
d'ailleurs je suis le seul sur le
contenu avoir publié qu'à avoir mis de
l'avant des politiques pour la défense
pour les garderies pour les climats pour
des ressources aujourd'hui alors c'est
un contenu et je leur en public les gens
jugeront très bien depuis qu'elles sont
avant de laisser aller la guerre est ce
que monsieur trudeau en fait assez à
votre avis pour aider l'ukraine
c'est pas un enjeu partisan j'aimerais
j'aurais voulu voir le canada fournir
davantage d'armes létales pour venir en
aide aux ukrainiens je pense que nous
devons soutenir également les pays
environnants comme la pologne et des
réfugiés qui vient de chez nous à des
conditions qui leur permettent de
retourner dans leur pays lorsque ce sera
terminé et de les aider financièrement
alors c'est pas un enjeu partisan mais
je regrette le fait qu monsieur roy
parce qu'on ne constate aujourd'hui que
le canada tellement laisser aller ses
investissements au niveau de la défense
nationale auxonne enjeu de souveraineté
et il ya une leçon à tirer de sympa ça
on n'y voisins des russes d'un arbre moi
de ma politique de défense je propose
d'ouvrir deux bases militaires dans
l'arctique justement pour qu'on puisse
assumer notre souveraineté toucherai
qu'il n'y ait pas un francophone dans le
conseil d'administration du cn siège
social à montréal quand j'ai entendu
dire je veux pas commenter ça ça super
pole vous êtes aspirants premier
ministre est-ce que c'est acceptable
comment vous qualifier la situation il
faut il faut que tu es un francophone ou
des francophones au conseil d'annuler
sont saines sur et ils se sont engagés à
le faire ils le feront sans doute j'y
étais
ils sont très conscients de leurs
responsabilités
alors donc il ils ont dit qu'ils le
feraient ils doivent le faire sur quoi
tout charest ya des dates donc début
juin c'est la fin de la vente de cartes
3 juin il y aura des débats au mois de
mai trois débats on va suivre cette
course là qui va a culminé au mois de
septembre 10 septembre de septembre jean
charest point ces sommes seront abordés
charest à la prochaine pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit